during the Trump Administration Trump
was a ratings machine why because every
news media Outlet could find something
to talk about something to scream about
something to be upset about rather than
enough tweets and more than enough
tweets from Trump and there's this and
there's this everyone on the business
side talking about CNN's product problem
that after Trump left the White House
and when Biden came in in February of 21
20 was inaugurated January February
there we were in the middle of the covid
crisis so it was coveted coveted covet
on the news but there is no more Trump
Stories the main story was covid and if
you took surveys from the American TV
watching consumer they were getting very
fatigued by covid by this time they were
locked out of jobs the work from home
thing was there their kids were locked
out of school and people were getting
very impatient very frustrated by the
whole covet Apocalypse of lockdowns